tuitions yes would you explain that one
well he has the notion that uh again
that that good things happen naturally
i have to bare things it's because uh
institutions including civilization
itself have have made these bad things
happen and of course uh so it's kind of
like like again back to the credit
example
like oh it's society
so in that example like the
like the way he's talking like it's like
society is making us do these spending
habits and i would save if it wasn't for
society okay does that make sense
yes and i think that that's really the
the implicit assumptions behind a lot of
things that are said on the left today
and
why in my most recent book i go to a lot
of trouble to show that uh
in nature uh there's nothing resembling
equal opportunity that wherever you look
around the country around around the
world
you find people who live up in the
mountains poor and backwards even in the
richest countries
including the united states
i believe the poorest country in the
united states the county rather
uh was in a mountain community
uh which was almost 100 percent white
somewhere in appalachia west virginia
yeah southern ohio right yes
and that men in that in that county
had a life expectancy
10 years less
than men
in a in a county in in virginia
and the constrained the unconstrained
vision says let's fix that we surely we
can pass a law that would improve that
and the constrained vision says well now
wait a moment
if people who live in isolated pockets
and mountains are poor and backwards all
around the world and we see this pattern
over and over and over again maybe
there's something very deeply rooted in
reality about that
that's hard for us to get at correct yes
all right
so in the book a conflict of visions
you're very dispassionate and very
analytical
and you lay out the unconstrained vision
and you lay out the constrained vision
and you don't really come out blazing
in favor of one or the other no
yeah that is not a book meant to commit
to uh
show one vision is is better than the
other it's there to show you what what
they are and what you're assuming if you
if you go one direction or another okay
and it's to encourage people to
understand the implicit assumptions
behind all this without which you're
just at
luke
would you say that the government um in
the states is more
constrained or unconstrained
i think it depends on the state
i think texas is more unconstrained i
think california is more constrained
okay
i can see it yeah
it's
it's so like hard because you
you want to be able to like
depend on the government to
help out everybody but in the grand
scheme of things
it's just not gonna happen i think the
problem is there's unintended
consequences like they say the path to
hell is paved with good intentions so
i'll give you an example in california
um in california they wanted to help the
homeless population
so they gave out um they're giving money
to homeless people people that are
homeless
and that resulted in people moving to
california to be homeless
wow yeah and there's a guy on the um
that they recorded he was like being
interviewed and he literally tells them
he's like i'm a crackhead i moved from
texas to california so i could be
homeless because they pay you to be
homeless here it's great i get 600 bucks
a month to just
but you see like so so again it's these
people saying oh i know what's best so i
know what's best for these people that
i'm not
and i'm i'm gonna pat myself on the back
oh look at me i'm helping the poor
wow unintended intentionally hurting
people that actually are functioning
members of society because now they have
to deal with all these homeless people
that
that is
that makes a lot of sense first of all
first of all 600 a month
for be homeless
it's
it sucks
to know that that's the thing because i
i literally would pack up everything
like i'm homeless like yo give me my 600
a month thank you
um
but they say that
the homeless in california are more
privileged than
any other like homeless population
anywhere else because they are in
california and it's mind-blowing like
you can be a privileged
homeless person
well and it's it's funny because maybe
it seems mean to say no you can't be on
the street but
it's it's not because it makes them
figure something else out is this and
some people don't like now
if someone's homeless
and
they wanted to
get on get on their feet now they can be
like well
i don't have to have responsibilities
don't have to work and i'm getting 600 a
month i'll just stay homeless like in
california
they have
areas where they have built
houses
tent houses and they'll have tvs they'll
have cabinets they'll have everything
just on the sidewalk chilling like it's
an outdoor home i remember i told my mom
that she said that's not fair they can
be out there they got to pay rent that's
not fair that they can live out there on
their own and just take up the sidewalk
space like no they're gonna have to pay
something to be able to do that and i
was like at first i was like no like
they're homeless they can't do that what
are they gonna do and now i'm like oh
yeah you all live here
and make things higher i'm sorry and
you're getting six hundred dollars a
month
you better
chip in somewhere because everything's
hiking up and you know who they take it
from you yeah because it comes out of
your taxes
and that's how people don't
like another example i could think of is
they surveyed people and they said do
you care about the environment okay like
do you want to see the environment
improve people said yes
then they asked people would you be
willing to spend 30 out of your paycheck
to help the environment everyone said no
let them you know what it's gonna die
sooner or later just let it and so but
who are the people patting themselves on
the back the people that aren't the ones
i mean it does come out of their
paycheck too but they're trying to get
elected so they they go up and they get
to say yeah i'm fighting for climate
change i'm this that that but they're in
a higher income bracket they don't care
but it eliminates the middle class
because those are the people that have
to pay for it those are the people it
hurts
nah if you say it you paying if you in a
high tax bracket
it's coming out your paycheck don't take
it out of mind it's just a little chip
on your paycheck it's half of mine like
no you then oh my gosh then there's
there's unintended consequences for that
too how so okay so let's say you take it
more out of the rich people right
fine maybe we do it a little bit but you
you get too high
then the rich people don't want to
invest in society they don't want to be
in the u like people will move to save
their money
like people will move their money
overseas haven't you heard of that yes
but it's because like what like if i if
i'm a rich person and they the i'm in
the u.s i have to spend 50 of my taxes
go to the government
and i know in this other country 25 of
my taxes go to the government why would
i not move
especially when it's millions every year
and then the problem is like you need
rich people for society to function
because like like leaving let's take my
family right if we moved like
300 people wouldn't have jobs
wow or 200 however i don't know how many
people they employ but like a lot like
and so again it's it's back to that but
you wouldn't know that right because
it's kind of like you're not in that
situation but it's a lot of people like
like making laws about situations they
don't understand and that's why i said
what i said earlier man come on now just
help us out something rich people
i'm fans all right so
pondering all this i i noticed something
a
column that you wrote this is a couple
years ago in which you rebutted nicholas
kristoff of the new york times and
kristoff
had ascribed the gaps between african
americans and whites in america gaps in
wealth gaps in educational achieve the
usual gaps
two and this is a quotation from
christoph to the lingering effects of
slavery close quote oh yeah and here's
tom soul
quote
if we wanted to be serious
about evidence
we might compare where black stood 100
years after the end of slavery with
where they stood after 30 years of the
liberal welfare state in other words we
could compare hard evidence on the
legacy of slavery with hard evidence
on the legacy of liberals close quote
and so there it is life is hard you use
the word hard
you use the word serious you use
evidence
tom soul is a man of the constrained
vision through and through and through
correct yes
no no
thought yes you know
part of a vanishing breed i might right
so
when so when you were a marxist
the notion explain that because the mark
marxism
well but no yeah so that's probably when
i was a marxist i had the same
intellectual standards right
he may explain that quote a little bit
more but um
as a black person
i will
i will say that there
obviously there are effects causing
effects to everything and i will say
that there
are
effects from
slavery that happen in the states but
there are
now i believe that there are
so many ways that
black people can be advanced in the
world yes there are still things that
are
in play that
keep us in a certain situation it's
harder for us to get out but i feel like
now there's more
opportunities for
us to get out and
there's a lot of people who
who stay in that mindset like oh
we're in this situation we're
stuck in this area we can't get out
we struggled here we struggled there
trust me my family struggled from
day one struggle struggle troubleshoot
struggle
but it didn't stop
me and my family or me me and my
siblings from doing what we wanted to do
going to college being able just to live
our lives and there's some people who
don't
release that thought of like
this is going to be hard for us we can't
do this
and they stay there and so
i would agree obviously i would agree
with that quote like there
there are things that just happen in the
world that
we can't control and it's just a lasting
effect like you were saying earlier with
the tax bracket there's effects to
there's effects to anything and
everything that you do whether it's good
or bad
but in that
i feel like you have to
if it negatively affects you how can you
bounce back if it positively affects you
okay how can you
take that and run with it
yeah i agree
and that that's what eventually led me
away from it
i'm sorry guys no
[Laughter]
[Music]
no nothing's up or
not okay i'm sorry no no it's just like
um
i
i'm getting ready
um no it's just like um
i think that
i don't want to see it
so
i like having like conversations like
this with the other side
because i'm interested i'm interested to
see just to hear like what
what are
your thoughts about like this
yeah the effects okay it's more like of
course there's gonna be effects like
that that happened for
how long i don't think 400 years yeah
but it's more like what can you do about
it you can't you can't do anything about
it now like in 2022 so the only thing
you can do is try to be bet like
make right going forward i don't think
like like they'll talk about reparations
and stuff okay so reparations um
i've seen on a lot of videos like when
when the law was passed that
there
no slavery abolished it
there we were supposed to not
the slaves were supposed to get uh 40
acres of meal and i remember asking my
mom like who agreed on that why 40 acres
of meal and she like was telling me like
well back in the day 40 acres you had
your own land and a mule you were able
to
put crops and be able to um
plant and
have have land to do that and so
now i've seen people calculated like
well if we go back and we
talk about we get the 40 acres enemy and
then like they calculated like what else
would we get now and like
um
what's the word um
when interest
they've taxed interest on it and they're
like
we're old like a lot of money i'm like
if that was true today i would be a i'll
be a rich person if we got refrigeration
so
um
i don't know if that's possible or if
that's
ever gonna be a thing
but
so okay so
the the problem with reparations is what
what percentage of white people do you
think actually owned slaves
in the us
i don't
i don't know
it's less than one percent really yeah
and the other problem is money doesn't
solve poverty
if money solved poverty then like people
could just throw money at a poor person
and they'd become rich but we're lottery
winners
they're like they go broke faster than
anyone because they don't know how to
spend it yeah it's about like managing
money and being able to run a business
like i think reparations possibly at the
top like at the time
but you can't
like like how you're making people that
didn't do anything pay for something
their great great great grandparents did
even if you did the direct descendants
like most people immigrated here after
slavery
like my like i have a grandparent from
lithuania or a great grandparent from
life oh you're saying that
okay okay like and you have to
understand even and then what about the
white people that fought on the other
side
that fought against yeah
so it's it's almost like like i just
don't know how that would work it's like
you're i understand what you're saying
it's like you're grouping
everybody
all the white people together
when it's like
my my descendants did have nothing to do
we were
we were elsewhere when all this stuff
was happening okay i could understand
that yeah
and so i just i just don't know how they
would do it in a way that would like
make sense
like back then sure sure and then you
have to understand like how many people
really own plantations that was really
only the super rich people in the south
they everywhere what i said you go in
the south they're everywhere no i know
but who owns them that's what i'm saying
like like it's not the majority of
people back then yeah most people lived
in the north like because you have to
think about how many how like that was a
lot of land so you had to be a landowner
yeah so that's like the one percent back
then
okay
so i'm glad you said that i got my mind
thinking it's not
bad
it's not no it's not the internet
scares me a little bit
but it's it's good to have this
conversation like people want
people want like
to have these conversations but it's
like they're not open enough to be able
to sit down with someone and say this is
my opinion on a hard topic like slavery
this is my opinion it's like well how
can you say that when this and then it's
like i just want to hear what your
thoughts are and then you get me
thinking and i get you thinking it's
like okay i never thought of it like
that because if we honestly if we did
have
reparations today i think a lot of a lot
of black people would be out of tough
situations but i also think
a lot of black people put themselves in
worse situations because they don't know
how to manage money and if like the
first steps if they were like okay we're
going to give you reparations but you
have to go through
a class where it teaches you how to
properly manage your money because once
it runs out we ain't giving you no more
i mean nothing and so i think that would
be
a great first step to be able to
if if reparations was a thing
to be able to
help
the black community i just i don't see
government handouts helping like
a little bit right i think like maybe
initially but it i don't see evidence
that that's super helpful because you
take the homeless population how many of
them are using that six hundred dollars
a month to like package it or
invest in something like over a certain
age i think if you're
if you're homeless like you you've made
choices to get there and i have
relatives that are homeless and the
reason they're homeless is because
they've stolen from every family member
that's let them
like live with them
and then nobody wants to take care of
them anymore and now they're homeless
and i know maybe like a lot of people
are going to say like that's i come from
a very privileged position i totally do
i but i just think you know you get out
the house at 18 if you're 45 and still
in that situation you did something
wrong in the past 20 years you couldn't
have been good with money yeah yep
i agree with that wholeheartedly because
i have conversations with my family like
if we're in the same situation next year
we did something wrong like if
you're if you
are put into a position and you
there's steps to where you can change
your situation but you don't decide to
change that means you don't want your
situation to change at all yes there may
be obstacles in the way you may have to
jump through some hoops it may be harder
but
i feel like everyone has the opportunity
to change their situation well it's kind
of like you right like why are you doing
this youtube channel right now because
you showed up on time
and you were helpful and so i said like
come on and now and now i pay you to
come on
right so it's like that's an opportunity
that you got because you showed up on
time
yeah and helped out early when no one
else was really helping
and so that's what like i i just i kind
of have a pessimistic view of people in
general i think most people like
don't show up and they don't try
and like and i think you can see it in
the us at least because most people get
overweight over time yeah and that's
that's a direct indicator of how much
you try
i think
you think that's wrong
i don't know if it's a direct
indicator
because
i'm trying to like think
i think it's
a source yeah one of them one of them
yeah it's like discipline on some level
because i've been over 200 pounds i've
been big and it was because i wasn't
trying hard enough at losing weight
it's just an indicator that
like you said discipline you don't have
discipline
oh i see in other words i did i hadn't
done all the research i hadn't gone
around the world
looking for evidence yes yes okay so
and so socialism is a great idea
that does not mean it's a great reality
one of the things that disturbs me
tremendously is about this enthusiasm
for bernie sanders and socialism at a
time when people are literally starving
in venezuela an oil-rich country
you know
and they you know they're breaking into
in the grocery stores to try to get food
and they're fleeing to neighboring
countries most of which are not all that
prosperous themselves but they but at
least you don't starve to death in them
uh and none of that makes a bit a bit of
difference
i don't think most of these people who
are out there cheering for bernie
sanders have given a thought to
venezuela
to the evidence that's right to the
evidence yeah all right
which brings us to
something that you refer to in a number
of columns you as the retrogression the
experience of african americans in this
country
economic progress i'm quoting you
despite the grand myth that black
economic progress began or celebrated
with the passage of the civil rights
laws and the war on poverty programs of
the 1960s the fact is that the poverty
rate among blacks fell from 87 in 1940
to 47 in 1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of a previous economic
trend but at a slower rate of progress
it was not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that is sort of i i i i have more i
wouldn't than my most recent book uh
discrimination and disparities
i point out that this really is a
pattern not continuing to blacks or even
to the united states that you can see
the same thing in england you can see it
in any number of other countries that
the poor or were much worse off
economically let's say in the first half
of the 20th century
and yet they in terms of their own
behavior
they were they were they had they were
far more decent
societies
i and and afterwards after after this
welfare state that's supposed to make
them better off and and better human
beings that's when the crime rate
skyrocketed on both sides of the
atlantic
uh the british were not famous for being
perhaps the most polite
considerate society in the world
prior to that
uh after that you get things like the
2011 riots over there
london manchester united where they
where they're going through this they
they they
anticipated ferguson uh and uh and
baltimore
by a few years
and the same thing is the the burning
down of buildings the throwing of
gasoline bombs that pull the whole smear
and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
trying to understand so he was saying
that
as the
poverty level
decreased
the crime level increased
um i think he's saying that when they
introduced the welfare state
okay and before the 60s like
people were poorer but there was less
crime and they were more polite and they
they acted more like decent in society
okay but then after the 60s or 70s when
the welfare state was introduced so that
was when um
they were he's probably going to get
into this in a second but like they were
incentivized to take the data out of the
home because they would give money so
again that was a that was the intention
was let's help the single moms that are
struggling so then but then what's the
government doing they're incentivizing
people to be single moms they're paying
you
per kid okay i
i do understand sorry guys i'm a little
slow
they use big words i'd be like
i like understand it but then i need
like another like explanation but i
i do understand that because
where i read it at there was a certain
point where they did
take the fathers out the home
and
i don't i don't understand why
and i don't know if it was because like
oh you get an incentive from government
if the father's not there i can get paid
cool
but
in the grand scheme of things it's not
helping
and it's just
a tactic that started and has
continued for years now and it from the
inside out has
just
i would say
taken a toll on the black community and
i wish i wish things like this
information like this was taught in
school so
people would know like what what
actually happened what
what was going on and why these certain
things happen instead of just like the
overarching theme like oh there was this
there was that and this is why this
happened yay great
but i think like if that was taught
then people would have people be able to
think differently and have a different
view and those laws wouldn't be able to
control people you have to think about
like when you when i look at a policy
you have to like i always say this you
have to think about it in the extreme
what is it incentivizing people to do
so if you give money to homeless people
from the government more people are
going to take advantage of it and it's
the same thing it doesn't mean all
people will because there's good people
and bad people but when you give people
the opportunity in a society to do the
wrong thing more people do it especially
when there's money involved
and i've heard of people having a kid so
they can get more money from the
government yep it's a thing like that's
so imagine being that kid
i couldn't i don't care how much money
i'm getting from the government i'm not
i'm not about to take care of a kid have
a kid no we're childless guys period
childlessness
but we don't want kids no okay
but
it's
it's
irritating to
that that's a thing that you you do
something because you know you're going
to get money from it but you don't think
about
the consequences or the how it affects
the other people that come in especially
in the kids situation when you
say oh i know i'm gonna get this type of
money i don't want to get um
i forgot what the word is but they get
moms get benefits to where they are able
to buy things it's like yes that's great
you're helping the single mom but if
your i your thought process was to
have a kid so i can get money so i can
be ballin it's like you're putting that
child in jeopardy and you're teaching
that kid like oh you don't need to do
anything for your own you can just
depend on the government to be able to
take care of you and you'll be fine you
can do exactly what i did i don't
i don't
no i don't like that i think not i think
but you should you should do things on
your own and if it
if you
you should just do things on your own
and not be like i'm just going to live
my life just
for
nothing and just depend on the
government the whole time yes there's
people in certain situations to where
it's like they
can't do nothing but depend
on i don't say nothing but they
have to depend on the government until
their situation change but i don't think
that should be your initial thought like
i'm going to do this i can depend on the
government my whole life yeah but that's
why the government has to make sure
people aren't taking advantage of it and
that's why a lot of times it sounds
harsh especially like you know the when
the wealthy like like the upper class
will say oh no we don't want government
handouts but it's not because of a lack
of empathy like my parents are very
against government handouts but they've
taken in three kids that were in bad
situations but they didn't they weren't
looking to adopt they just found the
kids in bad situations
but
how did i put this like the issue is is
from a policy perspective you can't give
people too much free [ __ ] because
there's unintended consequences that you
don't you don't initially think about
and then it's the same thing
those politicians will say i fight for
single mothers i fight for the lower
class but they're they're killing these
community they're like tearing apart
communities because there's more and
more
single mothers because they know that
they can get benefit so you have more
and more young women
not thinking about the consequence of if
i have if i have sex with this man
there's a possibility i may get pregnant
but it's so it it makes it essentially
easier like oh it's okay i know that i'm
gonna get money from the government but
they don't think about
the child's life
their life and how it affects it as a
whole but in the end i get money from
the government so that's all that
matters and then the other person like
do you know single women older women are
the biggest like increasing sector of
homeless people
really yeah because they and it's um sad
i hear a lot of girls talk about how
they they are like afraid to settle down
with a guy because they know they have
to take care of their mom someday
because of the choices she made
and they don't want to they can't see
their mom get homeless
whoa
that's a d yeah because at some point
like the the free ship from the you need
2.5 million to retire
people need to be married like you you
can't do it on one income and so you
have all these single moms that
they're not prepared and then it takes
one cancer diagnosis to put them on the
streets yeah wow
and this is all from an unintended this
is all a consequence from someone's who
said let's help single moms
and it's
effectively destroyed a lot of different
communities
you can't once you cannot see it oh my
you cannot see it oh my goodness oh
poor people were doing if the lesson of
the 20th century is something like poor
people including in this country african
americans
were improving their lot and leading
fundamentally decent lives until the
government decided to help them yeah yes
that's a that's a fair statement
they're better off uh
economically because of what's been
given right but of course when you when
you have the crime rate
i mean i i got i got the first inkling
of this some years back when i was uh
at some school in harlem doing some
research
and i looked out the window and i
mentioned in passing that when i was a
little kid i used to walk my dog in that
park
and looks of horror came over the
students faces
nobody in his right mind would have a
child going to that park
walking a dog or not
the principal was warning these students
not to cross this park which is about a
block a half wide
even in groups of six
uh when i and when i tell them about how
in this hot summer nights i would sleep
out on the fire escapes in harlem
they looked at me like i was a man from
mars people were doing that all over new
york they were doing it in philadelphia
washington wherever i've known people
that was a common thing for portland we
didn't have the money for air
conditioning right you slept out on the
fire escape or in the parks
where walter grew up in a walter
williams walter williams grew up in a uh
a housing project in philadelphia he was
saying on the hot summer nights the
people would be in this project would
have little balconies they'd sleep out
on the balconies and the ones on the
first floor who didn't have balconies
would sleep out in the yard
and that there were old men who would
you could see sit on a hot summer night
sitting outdoors into the wee hours
playing cards or uh or checkers or
whatever
it was a different world
[Music]
infinitely safer now what about family
structure
you would think
that
having
being more like
economically like wealthy and getting
help from the government it would
essentially
make people's
their you would be see a better way of
life
but to hear him say that when
they weren't getting handouts from
the government where they weren't
getting government benefits it was
essentially better and safer and it
changed when this is like
i'm trying to wrap my head around and
understand like
why why is that because money doesn't
fix problems that's that
but like
how many nba players go broke
a lot those are those are guys that get
to live a better life than like anyone
in history they get they get to be young
and wealthy which is rare right most
people if they are wealthy they're old
so they get to experience their youth
as many women as they could possibly
want
and and half of them go broke because
they they're it's like quick money and
and i just think
like
it doesn't it doesn't solve your
problems like they always say money
doesn't
change who you are it shows who you are
so
yeah
wow
okay so with that
that quote
oh my brain is like everywhere right now
because
it's
it's hard to
to know that
before the government stepped in and was
like hey we're going to
essentially help out this community
where where would
where would we be now where would black
people be now if that never had happened
would
we be
less than where we are now or
better they were economically outpacing
white people before like they're growing
like yeah and one of the one of the
minimum wage laws actually the the
biggest
in california one of the first minimum
wage laws actually disproportionately
affected young black teens
because what did it do like they a lot
of people say it was racist
because instead of hiring the teenagers
and that was like one of the most like
that was
the people that were the most affected
because that's what happens you you work
your way up to a higher income yeah
wow
and so yeah and it's crazy because
it's really hard to explain this to
people because they really make you out
to be you see how they paint
conservatives in the media
like it's not
they they make you out to be like oh
you're not helping poor people when like
honestly
conservatives are like the most giving
people they just do it privately
it's not like they're not leaving your
face well because people are more
charitable the more money they make
they just not not to the government so
like when people like like even with the
um with the environment like the one of
the number one indicators that um a
community is going to care about the
environment is that they make money like
that the economic prosperity that's why
you see like rich neighborhoods it's
nice
because when people have money when
you're poor like you don't have time to
care about other people
you're trying to figure out yourself
yeah yeah but that's that's where you
get these like huge donations a lot of
the time
interesting because i know
if i was up in that tax bracket i'd be
like oh yeah i would be more willing to
give out money here and there to help
people but but you also i'm going to
tell you the other side of this people
like because when you're when you're
wealthy when you're wealthy
people really take advantage of it like
and this is coming from up from like
i've seen my parents get backstabbed by
people that we have let them live with
us
we have let them because they'll just
think oh they're rich it doesn't matter
and like like we had a nanny
we were employing her we
we we were paying like she was going on
trips with us she had all this [ __ ]
hits the hand that feeds you because she
she stole like they she bought a laptop
off of like on their credit card oh wow
and it wasn't a lot of money to them
right but it's not about the money it's
like they're principally yeah it's like
it's the respect thing
and
that's
that's the problem it's like a
double-edged sword like because you want
to be and and we are like you know i
mean they took in three kids that
weren't theirs but it's just like
it's i think it's part of human nature
to be honest to see how much you can get
away with
yes yes it is
man i'm still stuck on that quote you
said earlier
oh
just
you can't see it